I have a drone in my purse
there's a drone in here you don't
believe me I don't know why you wouldn't
believe me why would I lie to you inside
my bag I have the new DJI Mavic see if
you guys are new here I've become
obsessed with drones in the past couple
of years one of the real struggles of
drone flying is not actually flying it
it's transporting it they're usually
pretty big there's propellers there's a
lot of stuff you got to do now inside my
purse this is going to change everything
controller plugs right into your phone I
[Music]
told you I had a drone in my purse this
is so small so compact I actually almost
cried the first time that I got a demo
it's not only is this super small super
compact but it still shoots 4k video it
goes up to 4.3 mouths when you're using
the RC controller you can also flying it
using your phone so you don't even need
this controller I'm a huge fan of the
controller because you can obviously get
a little bit more precise when you're
flying it but if you need a little bit
of extra space you don't even need this
so you might be looking at this
wondering how does this fly it unfolds
so it expands to roughly the wings band
of the Phantom 4 so here's where you put
your SD card this is also where you
switch the little switch here to go from
RC to Wi-Fi mode so in RC mode you're
going to use the controller and Wi-Fi
you use your smart phone something that
I absolutely love is this little
protective cover so if you travel a lot
and you transport your drone this will
protect your camera you can also fly it
with this on it if you're a little bit
nervous about your flying skills but
because it's plastic you do want to take
it off to get the best shots it has two
sensors right here on the front has two
sensors here on the bottom and also a
camera so this will help with your
precision landings and those little
sensors there will keep you from running
into things they are only on the front
and on the bottom so if you are flying
backwards you definitely need to be a
little bit careful here's the battery
super simple pops off I've got a couple
extra batteries these batteries will
also give you about 27 minutes of flight
time which is pretty long time actually
the controller charges with the micro
USB so you just stick this in here then
you plug this into your battery and
everything is awesome sometimes in video
it's really hard to tell the size of
things so I just cannot reiterate how
compact and awesome this is folds up in
seconds I'm going to find some things
around my room to give you guys a size
comparison to show you just how small
this actually is
Apple watch iPhone this is the iPhone 7
plus mind you about a lint roller my
shoe like my shoe please
it's my only shoe goodness a bag of
marshmallows this is a drone
this is marshmallows how about a LEGO
version of myself ago I think you get
the point so back in the Phantom three
days this is what it used to be like
when I'd want to go on a hike
[Music]
this was my life before Mavic and before
the phantom4
this inside here is the Phantom 3 I
decided that I wanted to get the
propeller on backpack because it'd be so
much easier to just open it up and go
yep good idea this is huge
I would carry this freaking thing up a
mountain and there we go my phantom 3
baby we've had some time is my friend
we've had some times just even fit in
the frame do you get the point you get
the point now let's do the size
comparison the Phantom 4 which has been
one of my favourite drones to date until
I saw this one Sam for you gotta put all
the propellers on there's batteries I
usually was flying with an iPad
connected to the controller wingspan
pretty much the same definitely a little
bit less hey guys you see that so here
is our Mavic and phantom for comparison
I mean this is I mean this is great
here's our battery comparison oh here's
our controller size comparison okay
I have eyes I can see so it's pretty
simple to set up
you just plug in your iPhone here pop it
into the controller obviously if you
have a bigger iPhone it's going to be a
lot easier to see the screen so it's
pretty surprised because I'm pretty used
to flying with one of the mini iPads so
being able to go from a mini iPad to an
iPhone I thought there would be a lot of
difficulty but it actually was pretty
easy let's start this little guy up I'm
not gonna fly in the house because I
have tons of demos to show you guys
right after this video
connecting basically ready to fly
[Music]
the first thing we're gonna do is we're
gonna go kayaking because sure why not
and the best part about kayaking is they
have tandem kayaks so I can pilot the
drone and Jenna can paddle wait a minute
yeah let's go